the marvel cinematic universe is getting
a little smaller as thousands of
theaters around the world decline to
screen its recent movies here's why
countries around the world are
apparently banning the series new movies
and what it might mean for the future of
the mcu thor love and thunder is finally
here and the film's early box office
numbers indicate that it's going to be
another financial success story for
marvel and disney according to the
numbers taika ytt's follow-up to thor
ragnarok gave the god of thunder's solo
franchise its biggest opening to date
having made over 300 million dollars
after its first weekend in theaters
that's a lot of dough for the space
viking this is despite the fact that
thor love and thunder has divided
critics and fans alike while some people
enjoy the humorous take on the thor
mythos others feel like the movie is too
jokey for its own good however mixed
reviews could be the least of the film's
concerns as it continues to roll out in
theaters worldwide while thor love and
thunder is shaping up to be an
international super hit the movie looks
set to be banned in certain regions that
have been profitable for hollywood
blockbusters in recent years if the
movie does indeed face the chopping
block in these regions it will mark yet
another disney release to be banned for
the same reason in
2022 the rainbow
bring the rainbows at catchphrase or
something
thor levant thunder is the latest disney
release to feature brief moments of
lgbtq representation which could prevent
the movie from being granted a release
in china and other territories the
latest marvel release implies that
valkyrie is bisexual with her mentioning
she had a girlfriend back in the day it
also reveals that korg is effectively
gay being a part of a species that only
has one gender industry experts believe
that these aspects will be enough to
stop the movie from being released in
certain regions taika ytt and natalie
portman have also been celebrating the
lgbtq aspects of thor love and thunder
with the pair having recently described
the movie as quote so gay and quote
super gay at a q a and screening however
they were subsequently criticized by
marvel fans as scenes involving positive
lgbtq representation in the movie are
actually few and far between which is
unfortunate considering the film is
reported to have originally included a
significant romantic scene involving
valkyrie that was cut presumably to
appease censors it's an unfortunate
happenstance especially seeing as how
valkyrie was supposed to have her
sexuality play a more prominent role in
thor ragnarok but that ended up getting
cut as well if the situation follows the
same trajectory as the light year which
includes a same gender kissing scene
thor love and thunder could also be
banned in territories such as the middle
east malaysia and indonesia reportedly
the disney pixar release is currently
banned in 14 countries
okay we should go
thor love and thunder isn't the first
marvel film to have an issue getting
released in other countries and if
current trajectories are any indication
it certainly won't be the last phase
four of the marvel cinematic universe
has been faced with bands around the
globe particularly when it came to the
release of eternals that film faced
bands in kuwait qatar and saudi arabia
due to the inclusion of a same-sex
relationship in that movie fastos is
married to a man named ben and the two
share a kiss homosexuality is banned
through much of the region and movies
depicting lgbtq relationships tend to
get banned that was the case with the
most recent marvel flick before thor 4
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness that film was banned in the same
countries seemingly due to america
chavez's parents being in a lesbian
relationship additionally those movies
as well as chongqi and the legend of the
ten rings were banned in china for
various reasons it remains to be seen if
the next movie in the mcu black panther
wakanda forever will make its way to
china's shores but things aren't looking
hopeful despite that these movies seem
to still be making plenty of money no
matter what
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the marvel cinematic universe are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
you